tu as grandi dans cette maison pourquoi
tu veut la vendre c'est la marche à
suivre après le décès de quelqu'un
le système de sécurité entièrement
automatisé et fenêtre d'en bas ont des
volets rétractables
c'est une vraie forteresse il semblerait
que certains deviennent paranos
vieillissant
vous êtes une femme seule à la merci de
parfaits inconnus
on trouve le coffre et en ce cas ce je
vous en supplie relâche et mes enfants
vous allez devoir faire exactement ce
que je dis vous vous et vos gosses vous
vous en tirerez pas vivant ce soir
you
les parties trouvent là
on assez casse elle ira nulle part
il est en panique je suis une mère vous
n'avez aucune idée de ce que je suis
capable de faire
fallait pas venir phénicie connard
[Musique]